à notre appel le 18 juin deuxième tour
des législatives
notre résistance peut gagner la bataille
c'est ce grand soin qui par
circonscription sera soumis aux français
lors des législatives
la campagne présidentielle est à peine
terminée que commence déjà la bataille
des législatives
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et c'était
aussi le cas en 2017 allez on va acheter
un petit coup d'oeil dans le rétro
il est 20 heures le 7 mai 2010 est
emmanuel macron est élu président de la
république quelques minutes plus tard
son adversaire du second tour marine le
pen prend la parole pour se placer en
première opposante au nouveau président
en vue des élections législatives le
premier tour a entraîné une
décomposition majeur de la vie politique
française par l'élimination des partis
anciens ce second tour organise une
recomposition politique de grande
ampleur au taux du clivage entre les
patriotes et les mondialistes
c'est ce grand soin qui par
circonscription sera soumis aux français
lors des législatives
ce soir là un autre candidat lance sa
campagne des législatives c'est jean luc
mélenchon fort de ses 19 5% des voix au
premier tour de la présidentielle des
gens ne lâchez rien nous renoncer à rien
ce pays et les gens simples qui le
peuple ne sont condamnés ni au pouvoir
des riches ni à celui d une
une nouvelle majorité parlementaire est
possible autour de nous le goût du
bonheur reste contagieux à notre appel
le 18 juin deuxième tour des
législatives
notre résistance peut gagner la bataille
et je vais m'y employer avec vous de
toute mon énergie du côté de la droite
en 2017 les républicains veulent se
remettre rapidement de cette défaite à
la présidentielle et tourner la page
françois fillon fini la campagne
présidentielle et avec elle les
républicains veulent enterrer le projet
de françois fillon aux côtés de leurs
alliés de lui dit ils ont donc présenté
leur nouvelle copie rédigé en trois
jours une synthèse avec comme maître mot
le pouvoir d'achat un mix des projets de
juppé sarkozy et fillon
une synthèse dont la droite n'est pas
familière mais ne leur dites pas que
cela ressemble à la synthèse socialiste
synthèse molle
formateur le projet de monsieur mac os x
à monsieur mâcon si vous voulez mais ne
dites pas à la droite et au chant et en
2022 le discours d'eric woerth sur
emmanuel macron a totalement changé
puisqu'il a rallié pendant la campagne
présidentielle
[Musique]